there is a new sexual assault allegation
against Donald Trump in addition to the
what is it twelve or sixteen that
already exists and this is a really bad
one this is an allegation of rape now I
think because of the creeping
normalization that we've experienced in
the United States under Donald Trump for
the last couple of years it's crazy I
have to mention this but even one
instance of something like this for
Barack Obama would have been a 24/7
scandal on corporate and right-wing
media for weeks at least but it was
almost completely ignored by the Sunday
morning talk shows and got relatively
little coverage over the weekend first
of all we are talking here about
magazine advice columnist and former
Miss Indiana University II Jean Carol
who has accused Donald Trump of
attacking her and raping her at a New
York department store in the late 1990s
the Carroll says that she ran into Trump
in the fall of 95 or spring of 96 at the
Bergdorf Goodman department store in New
York City where she says he attacked her
in one of the dressing rooms claims that
Donald Trump pressured her to try on
lingerie grabbed her arm to pull her
towards the rest dressing room and then
I will read her quote and I warn you it
is extremely graphic and disturbing
quote the moment the dressing room door
is closed he lunges at me pushes me
against the wall hitting my head quite
badly and puts his mouth against my lips
I am so shocked I shove him back and
start laughing again he seizes both my
arms and pushes me up against the wall a
second time and as I become aware of how
large he is he holds me against the wall
with his shoulder and jams his hand
under my coat dress and pulls down my
tights I am astonished by what I'm about
to write I keep laughing
the next moment still wearing correct
business attire shirt tie suit jacket
overcoat he opens the overcoat unzips
his pants and forcing his fingers around
my private area thrusts his penis
halfway or completely I'm not certain
inside me this is an allegation of rape
she's alleging that she was raped by
Donald Trump now Trump is denied it says
he has no idea who the woman is a
picture has since been published of
Donald Trump with the accuser Jean
Carroll and close to total silence about
this
on the big5 Sunday talk shows ABC CBS
CNN MSNBC and Fox all have these Sunday
talk shows Mike Pence was interviewed
Bernie Sanders was interviewed no
mentions of the new rape allegations
against Donald Trump so a couple things
to talk about here first of all if the
corporate media were all as liberally
biased as Donald Trump and Republicans
and Trump's sycophants claimed corporate
media to be liberally biased this would
have been a topic of discussion
yesterday period number two the
hypocrisy of Republicans who uniformly
jump behind any allegation no matter who
makes it against Democrats like for
example against Bill Clinton juanita
Broderick in 1999 or whoever else they
now are ignoring more than a dozen
allegations against Donald Trump if this
is mere politics
why couldn't some of the allegations
against Bill Clinton have been given the
same benefit of the doubt as they are
providing to the allegations against
Donald Trump but in any other presidency
it's really important to understand this
would be front page news non-stop period
now I would also be curious to know
asking all the people who hated Barack
Obama and thought he was the worst
person in the world that he had
committed all sorts of crimes that he
was in some cases a shape-shifting
Antichrist that he was planning to
declare martial law and suspend the 2016
election to try to stay in power
indefinitely why is it that no one
thought to concoct sexual assault
allegations against Barack Obama I mean
not only are there not sexual assault
allegations against Barack Obama there
are not even what we could call
political sexual assault allegations are
against Barack Obama and for those who
say this is a tactic that the Left uses
against Republicans fake sexual assault
allegations why were there no sexual
assault allegations against Republican
president george w bush so the point is
it's not based in fact to claim every
president has sexual assault accusers
and they're widely understood to be fake
and it
to take down presidents No most
presidents do not have sexual assault
allegations levied against them and
Donald Trump having 12 or 15 or 80 I
don't even know what the number is at
this point including remember child rape
allegations which I have covered but
have not received nearly enough
attention this is different okay it is
not even remotely reasonable to say
presidents they always have all sorts of
sexual assault allegations against them
no Barack Obama didn't george w bush
didn't now as far as the corporate media
coverage is this not getting coverage
because even the reporters and the media
have become totally numb to and
desensitized the donald trump's
treatment of women is it that they have
calculated that there is little upside
to covering the 17th or the 19th or
whatever allegation because the first 12
or 15 or 17 didn't get traction what do
you think is going on here is what's
going on as shocking and disturbing as
that or is there something else that is
preventing this from getting coverage i
am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blink Asst
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is calm / Pakman
if you're watching on YouTube I've put a
link in the description I have listened
to blinka spokes about economics about
political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa k ma n